hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the topic of
sacrificial protection in The Wizarding
World of Harry Potter and the potential
reasons why this counter charm doesn't
seem to be used more frequently against
fatal spells like Avada Kedavra to begin
with sacrificial protection is an
ancient form of powerful magic often
referred to as a counter charm which to
be quite honest makes it sound rather
less powerful than it actually is as
rare as it is old this particular brand
of magic appears to come to a witch or
Wizard's Aid rather unintentionally
simply put when a witch or wizard
chooses to Forfeit their life in
exchange for the life of someone they
love the spell Works its magic initially
shielding their loved one from immediate
harm and then forming an incredibly
strong and long-lasting protective after
effect as dying in an effort to save
another person's life is seen as the
ultimate sacrifice by many it's no
surprise that this particular spell has
been known within some communities of
The Wizarding World as the ultimate
Protection One that may seem rather
Familiar of course this familiarity is
due to the fact that as many of you will
remember the sacrificial protection
counter-charm is the very spell that
saved Harry Potter's life as an infant
in fact it was the only reason he was
able to survive Voldemort's killing
curse and become the boy who lived for
at the mere age of one Harry was able to
walk away from the Avada kadaver curse
thanks in no small part to his mother
Lily Potter choosing to willingly
sacrifice her own life in an effort to
protect her son from what we know on
that cold and dark evening in 1981 on
October 31st in The Potter's home in
godrics Hollow Voldemort came hunting
for Harry known only to him as the
infant wizard prophesized to be his
downfall and although Lord Voldemort was
the most powerful dark wizard of his
time he never could have anticipated
just how disastrous his attempt to
murder a young child would turn out to
be
knowing that they were being targeted by
Voldemort The Potters invoked the
fidelius charm which was meant to keep
their location concealed from the dark
lord tragically The Potter's Secret
Keeper and supposed friend Peter
Pettigrew betrayed them sharing how to
find the family with Voldemort the dark
lord stormed the house and Came Upon
James first desperate to protect his
family James stood his ground between
Voldemort and his wife and child but the
dark lord was easily able to take down
James Potter with the killing curse
swatting him away like an insect with
the flick of his wand then Voldemort
came face to face with Lily Potter who
was all that stood between the dark lord
and his Target Lord Voldemort commanded
her to stand aside which of course she
did not what happened next was beyond
anyone's expectations despite Lily's
refusal to get out of the way Voldemort
cast his Vada cadaver curse as he had
done so many times before killing count
less other powerful witches and wizards
including James Potter just minutes
before and yet this time Lily desperate
to save her baby boy threw herself in
front of Harry to protect him and
protect him she did her act of throwing
herself in between her child and the
evada cadaver curse invoked the ancient
magic of the sacrificial protection
spell which then bounced the killing
curse back to the dark lord rendering
him a shadow version of himself for the
better part of the 10 years that
followed but how did this happen and why
didn't James's protective actions bring
about the same type of age-old magic I
mean he was also attempting to Shield
his loved ones from harm by standing
between Voldemort and his family so why
was he killed instantly with no
repercussions for the dark lord when
Lily's actions well yes they resulted in
her death also brought down Voldemort
one of the most powerful wizards of all
time and left her baby boy unscathed and
if sacrificing yourself for another whom
you care deeply for could save their
life why is it that more witches and
wizards don't perform this act of
protection wouldn't it stand to reason
that if put into that type of situation
almost every mother or father would
choose to die in exchange for saving the
life of their child especially since the
effects of this magic seem to have an
incredibly long-standing effect for
example due to Lily's sacrifice Harry
was able to receive protection from
Voldemort just by living with one of his
mother's blood relations her sister
petunia dursley so if sacrificing
yourself for your child spouse or loved
one could offer them that type of
incredibly powerful and effective
protection why don't more people use
this counter charm well as mentioned
earlier in the video not one person has
the power to actually wield or cast the
sacrificial protection spell on their
own rather the ancient magic seems to
appear appear when it detects a
sacrifice but that still doesn't explain
how it is that so many dark witches and
wizards like Voldemort have been able to
kill countless families without the
sacrificial protection counter charm
coming into effect surely there have
been innumerable sacrifices made by
witches and wizards attempting to save a
loved one's life in the face of death
well as it turns out it may be the fact
that Lily had a choice too as Voldemort
put it step aside that brought about
this particular brand of ancient magic
now whether he asked her to get out of
the way due to Severus Snape's desperate
plea for the dark lord to spare her life
or because Voldemort simply wanted to
eliminate Harry as fast as possible is
somewhat unclear but what is clear is
the fact that she could have used that
moment to run for her life she could
have tried to escape or fight back she
may not have made it but she could have
tried instead she chose to stay and not
only to stay but to die Lily Potter did
not run or cast a spell in an effort to
save herself instead she did what some
may view as the exact opposite she
intentionally stepped in front of the
killing curse to sacrifice her life in
an effort to save her son from harm even
if she thought he may be killed
immediately after her she chose to stay
and die despite the odds that her
sacrifice wouldn't make any difference
all she could think about was shielding
her son in that moment and as Destiny
would have it it was that very choice to
die when her life was not in jeopardy
that indeed made all the difference so
now we have a better understanding of
why these sacrificial protection spell
doesn't take effect more often however
in situations where a family member
could choose to save a loved one instead
of trying to escape a fatal situation
themselves why is it that we don't hear
more about sacrificial protection
occurring throughout the Wizarding World
as I mentioned wouldn't it stand to
reason that most families especially
parents would sacrifice themselves in an
impossible scenario if they knew with
almost complete certainty that their
death would result in their loved one
being irrevocably protected from that
threat well in this case I think the
answer can be chalked up to the fact
that this ancient form of magic while
incredibly powerful is also quite
unknown to the modern magical world in
the Goblet of Fire Dumbledore explains
how even Voldemort underestimated the
power of this type of magic saying to
Harry you would be protected by an
ancient magic of which he knows which he
despises which he has always therefore
underestimated to his cost I am speaking
of course of the fact that your mother
died to save you she gave you a
lingering protection he never expected a
protection that flows in your veins to
this day Voldemort even expresses
himself how he had forgotten about this
type of ancient magic and he was a
wizard who had left almost no stone
unturned when it came to powerful spells
dark or otherwise so if even the dark
lord had little knowledge of the
sacrificial protection counter-charm it
stands to reason the majority of the
Wizarding World probably knew nothing or
very little about it
there's also the fact that this type of
ancient magic has been described as
being rather unpredictable JK Rowling
herself has admitted that the effects of
the sacrificial protection spell weren't
an exact science and it seems as though
this brand of magic heavily relies on
the intentions of the witches or Wizards
involved in invoking the counter-charm
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think why do
you think this type of magic isn't used
more often please share your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign